Chifoumi ! Ah ouais mais bien sûr évidemment !
Hey mais c'est pas mal ton truc là je veut recommencer.
Salut à vous peuple d'Internet. J'ai le même T-shirt que lundi puisque je tourne cette vidéo lundi.
Du moins ce début de vidéo. Donc dans quelques instants on va se retrouver face à guillaume pley et on va faire
un jeu ensemble un jeu à base de chifoumi ouais !
Mais avant de commencer j'ai un cadeau pour vous. Je sais pas si vous vous souvenez, il y a quelques mois je vous avais parlé d'un
instrument qui s'appelle le "Dualo" et j'avais invité le créateur pour savoir quel était le
processus qui l'avait emmené à créer ça. Ca me fascine un peu. Il ya beaucoup de monde parmi vous, peut-être même juste toi juste là
qui sont allé sur le site qui sont les découvrir le produit qui se sont renseignés et du coup pour me remercier, ils viennet de m'envoyer un Dualo
du-touch S
Mais je les ai déjà si vous suivez mes vidéos vous avez vu que j'ai acheté le mien il y a quelques temps déjà.
Donc j'en ai un comme ça. D'ailleurs merci beaucoup merci à eux je mets le lien dans la description si vous voulez découvrir.
Mais moi je vais vous faire gagner celui-ci. Pour le gagner je vous mets un post sur Twitter aujourd'hui, vous répondez à ce poste
avec le hashtag Dualolicard
Parce que ça ne me fait rire ! Vous pouvez aussi mettre un petit mot en plus du hashtag ça fait un peu plus plaisir.
Et la condition pour participer c'est bien sûr de suivre mon Twitter est de retweeter le tweet en question.
Maintenant que ça c'est dit je suis
extrêmement ravi de recevoir Guillaume Pley sur la chaîne.
C'est devenu un bon pote, il m'a invité dans les émissions de radio et ça faisait longtemps qu'on voulait faire cette vidéo là ensemble.
C'est ce qui va se passer.
Il y a une bonne surprise à la fin ou une mauvaise ça dépend. Je vous laisse le suspens.
-On donne les enjeux ?
-Oui ok.
-On donne les enjeux de ce battle. Si jamais je gagne tu fais ma promo à la radio pour mon spectacle
-Ah ouais Mr est comme ça, très bien il n'y a pas de problème
Je peux même le filmer et je t'envoie la vidéo.
-Exactement !
- Mais comme tu ne gagneras pas malgré tes trucs et astuces
je peux m'avancer. Parce contre si je gagne
j'aimerais que tu fasses une vidéo un ton vraiment pourri par exemple tu pourrais
prendre les ondes de radio comme thème de vidéo.
-C'est juste ça ?
- Oui, il fait une vidéo sur les ondes de radio
Il y a un rapport
En plus je pense que c'est hyper intéressant donc je pense que c'est pas mal.
-Mais ça c'est un million de vues assuré ! Imagine je perds je fais une vidéo là dessus je fais un
million de vues je te demande de me donner tous les sujets de vidéos.
-Et si jamais tu fais un million de vues je refais la promo à la radio une deuxième fois il n'y a pas de problème !
-Effectivement guillaume peut gagner
largement, en fait tout est possible je sais pas ce qui va se passer on va faire ça en trois manches.
-D'accord.
-Pourquoi il est susceptible de gagner ? Parce qu'on sait que j'ai des astuces pour gagner ou chifoumi mais je vais les dire comme ça elles ne fonctionneront pas.
Au chimoumi, les gens ont tendance à commencer par pierre.
-Ok. Ah en génaral ?
-Oui sauf si tu leur fais un geste avant genre ça ils vont en parlant.
Tu vas dire "on fait un chifoumi" ils ont tendance à commencer par ciseaux. On peut se faire se faire influencé comme ça.
-D'accord.
-Quelqu'un qui gagne a tendance à refaire le même coup après et quelqu'un qui perd a tendance à changer
de coups dans l'ordre pierre feuille ciseaux.
-Ok. Ah c'est pas mal comme truc quand même pour gagner, on va voir si ça marche ! Parce que c'est bien beau d'avoir des trucs mais est-ce que ça marche ?
-Et tout est expliqué dans ce magnifique livre n'est ce pas.
-Je l'ai utilisé à la radio, je l'ai ouvert et il y a de très très bonnes choses.
-On est vraiment à armes égales
et je peux pas utiliser des petits trucs de mentaliste et tout, je suis vraiment en mode à poil c'est la première fois que je
fais un truc j'ai pas une longueur d'avance. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
C'est parti, première manche.
-Attends tu m'as dit qu'en général les gens commençaient par pierre... ok très bien. Attention.
Chi
Fou
Mi
[cri de joie]
Je sens que je vais avoir une vidéo sur les ondes de radio très prochainement sur la chaîne de Fabien Olicard !
Tu n'as gagné qu'1 coup sur 15 ! [rires]
Chifoumi
-Ah m***** !
Bon ! Ce n'est pas grave.
Chifoumi !
Alala ah c'est pas mal, c'est pas mal !
Grrrr !
-J'ai l'impression qu'on est à égalité !
-On est à égalité. On avait dit en 5 coups la manche mais du coup il faut qu'on se départage.
-Là c'est le dernier ?
-Mort subite de cette manche là oui.
-Ok.
Chifoumi !
-Ah pu**** tu l'as gardé !
-Voilà ! Pas desoin d'être mentaliste ici sur cette chaîne !
-1 point pour Guillaume Pley ! 1 point pour Guillaume Radio !
Nouvelle manche !
Est-ce que je peux faire ça comme signe ?
[rires] Est-ce que c'est possible ?!
Chifoumi !
-Ah mais bien sûr évidemment !
Eh mais c'est pas mal ton truc là moi je veux recommencer.
Chifoumi !
Je m'en doutais. En plus la tête de ma mère que je m'en doutais. [rires]
Je suis vraiment un blair
je suis un gros blair !
chifoumi
[rires]
-Oui parce que tu te dis il va mettre pierre, je vais lui mettre la feuille ! Eh ben non !
Chifoumi !
Allez !
Vous avez vu je joue le jeu, je ne regarde pas, j'essaye pas de deviner quoi que ce soit.
Ah oui ! [rires]
Le mec se met un point sur la feuille alors que je gagne ! Le mec m'a pris pour un...
Chifoumi !
Allez !
Plouplouplou ! Toutoutoutoulou ! [chante]
Chifoumi !
Ah ! 3-2 ?
-Oui, 3 à 2 là.
-Non t'avais pas dit à 5 ?
-Ah oui pu**** !
-Eh !! Il croit que j'oublie les règles !
-Ah oui, ce n'est pas le premier à 5. C'est en 5... Oh la vache !
-La vidéo sur les ondes radios ! [chante]
-Ah mais oui c'est vrai ! [rires]
-J'ai juste utilisé ton truc là c'est un peu comme l'histoire de la guillotine.
-Mais non, mais c'est parce que j'avais envie de faire une vidéo sur les ondes radio, c'est un kiff.
-Ah mais tu as raison parce que c'est très intéressant !
Vous allez découvrir des choses.
-Oh ben ça va vous passionner...mais alors laisse tomber quoi !
Comme je me suis viandé sur les deux premières, je te propose
de faire la troisième quand même, sauf que je vais jouer random et au lieu de décider ce que je joue je vais prendre au pif.
-Ok je ne regarde pas.
-Ok là je vais jouer ça.
C'est bon. Chifoumi !
Oh !!
-T'as trois vies. Ah ouais.
Chifoumi !
Je gagne. Je mélange, je mélange. Je mélange, juste je mélange. Je prends un papier.
-Attends, attends ! Je réfléchis.
-Il réfléchi à du random !
[rires]
-Donc vas-y.
-Chifoumi !
Il y en a là dedans !
-C'est complétement aléatoire !
-Attends je me retourne. Ah tu remets les papiers à chaque fois dedans ?!
-Oui oui.
-Ah mais c'est pour ça, moi je comptais, je comptais !
-Ah mais non ! [rires]
Chifoumi !
Allez !
Mais j'ai l'impression que par tous les moyens il ne gagne pas, bon... il va peut être trouver un truc un jour... mais enfin il ne l'a pas encore trouvé...
-Le mec il domine le hasard.
Chifoumi !
Oh !! Toutoutou [chante] Moi je m'en vais salut ! Bonne vidéo !
-Ce mec a gagné avec toutes les méthodes du monde.
-Bon vous allez apprendre des choses dans la prochaine vidéo de Fabien Olicard.
-Ah ! J'avais pas mis "enregistré" ! Désolé mec il faut qu'on refasse.
-Oh m***** !
Ca aurait été tellement beau.
-J'ai vu que tu avais appuyé sinon j'aurai eu peur.
-Donc je ferai une vidéo sur les ondes radio, alors peut être pas la prochaine,
mais promis elle sortira dans les semaines à venir.
D'accord. Et si elle dépasse un million de vues, je fais trois fois ta promo.
-Merci à toi Guillaume d'être venu ici.
Vous retrouvez Guillaume Pley tous les soirs sur NRJ à partir de 20H.
Cette année ça a changé c'est plutôt et c'est mortel.
-On a moins de cernes. Enfin...
-Merci beaucoup ! Abonnez-vous à sa chaîne je vous mais les liens de ta chaine Guillaume Radio et de la chaîne Gameplay.
-Oui exactement, l'autre chaîne.
-Qui est... qui s'est relancé il y a quelques jours.
-Ce monsieur va être dessus dans quelques jours d'ailleurs.
-Exact et t'as relancé, il y a 3 vidéos par semaine je crois ?
-Oui exactement.
Trois vidéos, on en met trois fois par semaine on vous fait des défis voilà. On va s'éclater. Et on va au stand de tir la semaine prochaine.
-Yes ! Allez checker ça, si ça se trouve elle est déjà sortie le temps que je monte celle-ci.
N'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en l'air c'est que ça vous a plu merci on vous aime abonnez vous faites des trucs soyez cool
Ciao !
-Big up les gars !
-Alors si tu crois aux ondes radio tu peux t'abonner en cliquant sur mon rond à moi.
Après il y a son rond à lui mais franchement...
-Ouais franchement le rond de Fabien Olicard il est quand même vachement plus beau que mon petit rond
donc abonnez vous plutôt en cliquant sur le rond de Fabien Olicard.
-Ah ! T'es fairplay, t'es gentil !
-Et ne l'oubliez pas le 29 octobre au Grand Point Virgule évidemment ! Merci à vous d'avoir suivi la vidéo.
Et bonsoir à vous !